das war eine komplett anders mit schale
hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video gerade übels hunger deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht die spiele app die was
mit essen zu tun hat ziemlich gute idee
dieses spiel heißt stalker kitchen
das spiel ist ab 3 freigegeben das heißt
es ist auf jeden fall nicht jugendfreie
sowie youtube main kanal in letzter zeit
behandelt wird dass ich wahrscheinlich
trotzdem ab 18 freigegeben seien
wir kriegen einfach mal auf play und
jetzt haben wir die auswahl zwischen
drei verschiedenen leuten ich würde
sagen wir nehmen einfach mein liebes
mädel hier oben der teller dreht sich
wir sehen rechts unten einen
pfefferstreuer eingeblendete das ganze
laden symbol der stadt davids und das
ist unser kühlschrank ich würde sagen
wir fangen direkt an richtig geilen als
die wir hier auf dem teller schmeißen
und ich würde sagen kollege du ist jetzt
einmal bekannt sich das essen das
wochenende komplett anders mit schale
aber ich werde ja nicht umsonst
meisterkoch genannt das heißt jetzt die
karotte stellte hierhin und ich würde
sagen wir gehen jetzt mal nach rechts
mal rechts können wir nämlich jetzt
beispielsweise zu dem messer gehen und
wir nehmen das messer und schneidet
jetzt die karotte war so ein bisschen
durch das hier oben kann bei abschneiden
das kommt nicht weg und das hier ist man
noch vermisst denn jetzt weggeflogen
ich schneide es durch und es gibt
einfach alles beck ich hab ich sie die
karotten liegen das heißt ich jetzt
rüber zum kochtopf und java ist meine
karotten top4 oder ok was haben wir
unten sei es etwa das heißt ein bisschen
salz noch in die suppe material machen
noch ein bisschen pfeffer mit rein kann
ich dann noch rein scheißen oder so und
ich kann dir ein scheißen da ist so ein
bisschen so wie dünnschiss aus also ich
kann also ein bisschen sojasauce hier
kann ich mein beckens nicht
heißes wasser mit karotten und sojasauce
immer wenn freunde weil wir sind
tatsächlich auch so deswegen will
wahrscheinlich auch keiner mehr bei mir
doch ein bisschen ketchup in die so
viele leute wer kennt es nicht beide
gott tut das ist hammer einfach nur der
pure hammer 80 trend gar nicht scheiße
2000 jahre später ich würde sagen wir
mal ein bisschen genug ketchup da drin
jetzt immer mal wieder zurück und jetzt
hat sie dann die klamotten und die
pustet sie jetzt erst mal bisschen
trocken und ein bisschen kalt und das
würde ich sagen immer dass man nicht
halte dass man in die fresse und jetzt
kannst du es nämlich essen
ihr schmeckt würde das nächste nehmen
wir mal eine zwiebel mein gott die
zwiebel ist was so groß wie ihr kopf
alter was passiert wenn sie die zwiebel
einfach so komplett ist afrika wir ihn
trotzdem war einfach jetzt ne zwiebel
mit mir hier noch ein paar pilze und ich
würde sagen dann nehmen wir noch so ein
bisschen fleisch und dann machen wir das
jetzt erstmal ein bisschen sehr accent
das fleisch wird so ein bisschen hier
ein scheibchen geschnitten und dann
machen wir nämlich gleich so eine
gemüsepfanne daraus alles hier schön
klein schneiden damit sie das gleiche
essen kann hier so dass hier noch ein
bisschen durch schnippeln und dass wir
vorne auch noch ein bisschen wie geh
wieder zurück und jetzt nehmen wir
nämlich als nächstes den pilz ich hasse
pilze die so mache ich das dem
wildschwein war auch so ein bisschen
durch damit sie sich dann natürlich
nicht was verschluckt so ist jetzt auch
jeden moment gleichkommt blick was
durchschnitt wie lange dauert das genial
nach und als letztes noch die zwiebel
die zwiebel an gemeinsamer so ein
bisschen klein weil die ja wohin die hat
auch vorhin überhaupt keinen bock auf
zwiebeln haben diese packende jetzt noch
eine zwiebel mit rain quin zeit wichtig
dass wenn man ein brettchen hat dass man
daneben schneidet also das ist als profi
koch macht man das so wir haben alles
klein geschnitten gehen dann jetzt mal
zur fahne und jetzt können wir glaube
ich hier unten nichts machen
wo ist der scheiß denn jetzt ich hab das
jetzt alles klein geschnitten und es ist
einfach weg bis ich habe ich drei vier
stunden damit beschäftigt diese scheinen
das fleisch so scheint es ist einfach
weg leute es einfach nicht mehr da
machen wir das ganze noch mal ich nehme
diesmal bei einfach mal nur das fleisch
und schaut dass wir auch damit
funktioniert dass wir nehmen das fleisch
schneiden das etwa so ein bisschen
hierdurch so hier ein stück after an
stuttgarts anstieg auf dann stück ab und
hier nochmal so quer durch dann ging es
wieder zurück
tatsächlich da das fleisch liegen und
das packen wir das fleisch in die pfanne
würzen das ganze mit ein bisschen seid
dann wird mir das ganze mit einem
bisschen pfeffer
dann nehmen wir noch ein bisschen die
throne darüber wie wir auch noch darauf
machen leute werden gedacht geschafft
wer kennt es nicht alle sind von von
roger dann auch mir das alles so ein
bisschen durch die fahne kann ich das
eigentlich nein kann ich nicht wie geht
wieder zurück jetzt hat sie das auf dem
teller und ich würde am liebsten hunt
marin was krasses kochen so mit zwiebel
und so wollte ich ja so eine komplette
gemüsepfanne machen aber es geht in
dieser ethnie wird fakt sie hat auf
jeden fall schon mal das fleisch auf dem
teller das heißt theoretisch könnte ich
ja jetzt den nudeln nehmen die nudeln in
den kochtopf schauen jetzt hab ich das
fleisch auch da unten okay jetzt mal
alles sind leute wisst ihr was fehlt bei
nudeln im kochtopf catcher wie nudeln
sind irgendwie nicht so gut aus ich
dachte die wären halt so eine komplette
masse dann oder so aber ich mag die
nudeln jetzt erst mal hier auf den
teller unten links rund die jetzt
versuche ich das ganze mal noch
irgendwie mit einer kartoffel handeln
mit kartoffel soll ich denn jetzt getan
ich nehme das fleisch und haut das hier
auf den teller drauf weil ich glaube
dass es so land tatsächlich
funktionieren können das heißt praktisch
kartoffel wieder zucken nein nein nein
das ist nicht wahr
das ist jetzt nicht wahr das kann nicht
sein als wir das jetzt alles weg ist ein
paar sekunden später
ich hab so gut gekocht und es ist jetzt
alles weg halt deine fresse leute ich
bin schockiert
ich kann das nicht mehr weiter machen
das ist traurig